what do we want and when do we want it
what do we want when do we want it I
think the movement is building in my
view school choices the civil rights
issue of the 21st century and and one of
the great strengths of the movement is
that it's no longer theoretical we are
seeing school choice programs balloon
them all over the country I was admitted
into my dream school Swarthmore College
in Pennsylvania and I'll be going there
this fall and I would not be able to say
that if I had not attended Westchester
Academy for International Studies if I
had not had choices now we see that
choice works that it's the most
effective engine for improving the
quality of education for giving kids who
are trapped opportunity for a better
education
I don't want to see less magnet I want
to see more and I want to make sure that
if there's a magnet school in your
neighborhood like Baylor medical middle
school that the name of the children can
go to the magnet school as well or the
local charter school or the public
school that they want to go to the
Democrats a great many of them are
almost unalterably opposed to school
choice programs because the teachers
unions are opposed to them on the
Republican side unfortunately there's
far too much apathy you have a dynamic
where the two parties neither one of
which is stepping up in a big way to
champion choice so how do you break
through that if you look at the
communities in which school choice
programs have been adopted there's a
unifying principle which is you have
leaders who step forward and they're
willing to risk everything are willing
to be voted out of office over expanding
hope and opportunity to kids who are
struggling and trapped in failing
schools every child in America deserves
a fair chance and quality education
Republicans should be going into
minority neighborhoods and saying we are
fighting for your children to give your
kids a better hope a better opportunity
because every one of your kids deserves
a fair shot at the American dream and
you know what I'd be thrilled if
Democrats came into those districts and
did the exact same thing I celebrate the
choice it allows people to move around
but I also celebrate the choice of
allowing people to go to a good and
solid excellent school in their area
just dumping money in the school
districts doesn't work many of the
school districts that are struggling the
most have had a bunch of money dumped in
them but if the kids don't have the
ability to choose if the kids don't have
the ability to bring competition to bear
quality predictably remains very poor
the outcomes remain poor we need to
empower kids and parents I'm convinced
too one thing which is parents love
their children a heck of a lot more than
the government does what school choice
is all about is giving low-income kids
the same choice the same opportunity the
richer middle class have always had
every kid in this country no matter
their circumstances no matter their
family background if given a fair chance
at an education can achieve something
extraordinary
and let's be honest we like choice
Michael Jackson or Priss for Mustangs or
dodge Rams Hot Cheetos or takis we love
making choices and those everyday
choices are just as important as the
choice of our schooling so I wish all of
you the best choices that make sure that
you choose what's right for you and
let's celebrate national school choice
week together what we want to do is take
a child and his or her passion what are
they interested in what are their needs
what are their talents and then we want
to match those up with a school that
specializes in those needs talents are
interesting and what we find is what if
what a child chooses that school based
on their own interests and needs magic
happens they make better grades they
don't drop out they're engaged with
their teachers are engaged with a
curriculum it's a school choices are
wonderful thing and out of our two
hundred and ten thousand students 69,000
chose to attend school and a school
other than the school in their
neighborhood we view kids and parents
because we're a school of choice we view
kids and parents as our customers we
need to serve I'm very motivated by
providing a voice for those kids who do
not have a voice at the table of
opportunity
give it a choice it improves their
reading scores their math scores their
ability to get into college their
ability to achieve a better future never
let anyone deny you of the importance of
being able to choose an excellent
education so let's have a great race
week send a message to Washington and
tell them we need more choice have a
great night Texas